[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this
video deals with the scotch four nights
and the way to get to that opening so
we're dealing with basically everything
that happens after e4 e5 Knight f3
knight c6 our choice is Knight to c3
which technically is the three Knights
game not a name that is particularly
popular or well known so I decided to
simply call this video squash for
Knights even though there are parts of
it about the three Knights game um but
three Knights again nobody knows what
that's supposed to be so why are we
going for the Scotch for nuts I just
want to show you first of all what that
is after Knight f6 my repertoire choice
is D form and after he takes Knight X we
reach the Scotch for Knights starting
position in a way so first of all this
is a very very well respected and and
classical opening it has been played for
a very long time the oldest game that I
have is from from the 1900s the Scotch
for Knights has a very sound and solid
reputation the reason is that White's
development is extremely fluid and quick
and we are also usually enjoying a very
very nice pawn structure that makes it
notoriously difficult to beat from the
black side I have my own experiences
there playing e45 for a long time with
the black pieces so this is our choice
against a 45 basically it will happen
most of the time and double King pawn
the alternatives just to give you some
insight what I was also checking the
alternatives that I checked are mostly
of course the ruler PES but Bishop to b5
the Italian game with Bishop to c4 or
the Scotch that is an irregular Scotch
move order um I was considering those
alternatives but the Royal peasant the
Italian game did not really in my mind
fit that bill of keeping it simple it's
just an extreme maze of variation in its
but particularly the rule of pest Black
has a really really huge variety of
ideas that you need to check the Italian
is a bit easier to access but it's still
it's still it's still huge also I felt
and this is my experience from being a
chess coach for a while
oftentimes if all players rather want an
open position it's called the open game
so they want an open position where they
can calculate variation and peace play
peace play is more prominent and this is
what you get with the scores for Knights
the position will definitely open up
this is not so much the case for the
Italian game or the wave because the
lines that actually promise something
are closed with d3 c3 slowish game so
this is my choice because I think this
is the open game of the open game so to
say in the Scotch I thought about also
going with the regular scotch remove
water 3d for right here but decided that
it serve our purpose is simpler to stick
to the other move water in the regular
scotch you can get the same position of
course and this will happen actually
quite frequently but black has some
additional options like Bishop c5 which
is the most popular alternative or
Bishop to before which I have played
quite a bit however if you know what the
squad for knights and after watching
this video and studying this on chesil
you will know it employing the regular
scotch is not a huge step so it can be a
very
welcome addition to your opening
repertoire later you have to check out
some line against Bishop c5 and before
and if you find something that you like
then we can already employ the opening
so it's an easy step to expand from what
you learned here so we go Knight c3 90
f6 as mentioned is the main move and by
far the move that you will face face the
most regardless of what your opposition
is it's fairly obvious that this should
be one of the main choices completing
the Knights development and preparing
cancelling however we need to check the
alternatives and they range none of them
is really great but yeah there's still
there are differences that same and I
want to start with the move that you
will encounter by comparison relatively
often the move Bishop to c5 this is
actually a nice thing about this move
honor was three Knight to c3 that this
move that looks completely normal and
natural is actually not that good we
gained a nice game nice advantage by
taking only five this type of yeah
pseudo sacrifice it's not really a
sacrifice and is well known in the open
games and here very nice for us we need
to check now two moves black recapturing
after which we get the piece back with
d4 or like giving up the bishop on f2
this actually happens quite often and
this is a good news for us because after
King takes Knight takes d4 our position
will be a lot better the reason is our
central dominance and the bishop pair
which is we had two advantages that ad
are very nicely however we need to check
one particular idea here that can be
tricky the move that I'm talking about
is the move Queen to f6 and this will
probably happen there
most of the time if black does not play
that and retreats with the night we will
let say he would go here or here our
simple recipe would be to Castle by hand
yeah Bishop e2 root f1 King g1 and the
Bishop ham and central advantage will be
very nice for us so the tricky move is
Queen j6 check we go to g1 and now an
important thing first of all to notice
is that we are not actually threatening
to take the knight yeah if we like that
say black plays Knight to e7 yeah we
cannot take this piece as Queen b6 is
all of a sudden a checkmate now that's
embarrassing
don't do that so important to note we
don't threaten the night if black
actually does play 97 and is here that's
a tricky move we should simply develop
this Bishop to e3 which covers
everything and now actually threatens to
take the piece yeah the same kind of
tactical idea could happen if let's say
black comes back and then you should not
do this and because they might take it
is again this idea so pay attention to
that
another tricky idea here for black is
not G form this is actually a move that
either losers or wins in a way because
black threatens here with mate and
threatens here and it's actually not
that easy now for white you only have
one move vailable that prevents the loss
but it happens to ya win is a bit strong
but it's close to it after Queen d2
covering here and here white is in fact
a lot better we have the already
mentioned advantages of bishop and
center and now on top this Knight now is
really on a bad spot for black if we go
h3 next the knight would have to drop
back to very miserable post on h6 so
this
on f2 it's an excellent position really
it's an excellent position for us after
95 the relatively better choice is
Knight takes e5 like just takes it I
hope you enjoyed this preview of the
keep it simple efore repertoire you can
get the full course on chasuble comm
which features the move trainer that
makes it easy and simple to learn all
the nice and remember them all lights
are chosen with one thing in mind keep
it simple for you and make it difficult
for your opponent
[Music]
you